so what's in the box
dude this is Dwayne the rock Johnson's
doom
this one's been requested for a while
never seen it what the game a game was a
shit ton of fun yeah uh communists at to
the movie apparently a lot of people
didn't like uh the one thing that gives
this whole snowing so bad they might be
ready hope it's our way to know that
that gives me everything's better see
some satanic shit in this movie yeah so
the game was all about it was you versus
space eight they better say big fucking
gun - we've never seen that before we're
curious how you screw up something like
doom it seems pretty easy not to screw
up so let's check it out this is our
first viewing of doom finally Universal
goes into the universe yeah just on
earth for so long come on wrench out
things stuff running stuff moaning oh no
are we doing that blurry Kim yeah they
mustn't run into a pipe and they just
cut away
[Laughter]
great start okay keep it going keep it
going
I'm sincerely hoping that wasn't just
the best part of the movie because I'm
like that was pretty good the rock with
this shirt off no now believe me shit I
don't believe your shirt either handle
any dread and lady Amir and the lady
home and all the deeds just everything
geek the more I think about it I fight
fantasies answer to every man yeah
you're right I can't tell if I'm
impressed or underwhelmed but there has
been like zero kind of plot development
yeah I'm just like on the one hand I'm
like this is moving in a really good
clip on the other hand I'm like well I
don't know anything about them all five
seconds away from retirement yeah
leftover Expendables though really
expendable I'm scared
Sarge don't worry rookie don't call me
that I'm dad present eight people die
you die welcome to the leftover set from
demolition man gentleman's oh yeah
what the hell is that okay gum glad you
weren't the one question I have no idea
what that a yeah what is that that was
Stargate seta to 1,000 songs what is
that oh we were take please don't get
near that thing it will leave no it's
right great okay now you know now you
know he went to one galaxy his ass went
to UAC does make the odd tiny mistake
that's like a Spaceballs accident hey
you're really wasting no time there just
that's right the fuck in this ant oh
yeah I'm liking them or not wonder level
5 quarantine so I'm just gonna have to
strip hormone I'm glad Space Marines are
recruiting serial killers yeah that
wasn't like hitting that is like I'll
take your clothes off with my teeth and
your skin I'll just say it
I love doors that open with puffs of
smoke I just love it any time they seem
like that's a heavy door all right draw
straws who's gonna die first the rock
hey yeah I think he's going first or on
the move I love you too what yeah why
did they have to build this place to
look scary where were parked in 2.3 all
this technology and they use a marker
putting axes no puffs of smoke and
immediately fail oh so that's where they
keep the rank oh it was his wife we
don't know lissa this is my brother John
another creature from the long lost past
why is she such a dick to him siblings
hate each other it's like the thing from
trick-or-treat below trick-or-treater it
takes the mask huh okay somehow we're
going too slow now get two monsters yeah
I got your Tic Tacs right here buddy
this was all just a really expensive M&M
commercial this is why we don't make
movies I was trying to look at that
fucking commercials like what was a line
of it's stupid covers they played before
every goddamn movie hello mr. satanic
Richard
don't try to talk to it and it just
chomps them to death I took his name in
vain this is the most unstable military
what the fuck that's I got like Marines
you discipline your train that it's is
like no these guys are all whack jobs
oh I said the S word I can't believe we
missed that guy take it this sweet time
now it's like it was going so fast and
now it's just say yeah okay we know
something's gotta be there it's like
we've seen this a million other movies
let's let's get to the damn thing you're
not smart enough to have us listen to
the scientific now and take it seriously
and build suspense I mean I don't know
old-timey sewers on a futuristic Martian
base yeah nobody really thinks sewers
Marcus I bet this was my brother's fault
idiot stupid what the hell's Carmack
anticipate when were you gonna tell me
yeah we know you're military and you're
all stupid
whatever my deal is no response
who's losing him yeah that's what means
moron weird god she had there we are the
reinforcements I thought we were really
expendable where the re Expendables walk
through the bubble wrap pop
this is where it happened back to my
flashback to happy birthday the first
movie wasn't up there we go it's big
very big moving fast food first
such speaks and Trump ease it's very big
very big we very fast military
scientists do not use numbers they're
just big fast how about it's
approximately 50 meters of moving at you
at 20 miles per hour yeah
kidneys Bob's got kidneys right okay one
more time there we go no no all right
man that's the best we're gonna send to
this you know the problem is okay aliens
they have a lot about a lot of suspense
but some of the action happens it
happens for a while this was like one
thing ah and then it's gone it's like
okay forever why are they all splitting
up like aliens they didn't do that they
split they basically split up into two
teams which is fine because they're two
teams in this fucking thing it's like
we're one team now let's all go our
individual ways here's the funny thing
about doom the game I don't remember a
lot of like sneaking around and being
clammer things coming out you've got
fuck you and shit again it's like not
one at a time getting picked off like it
really is not aliens no even aliens have
more that's not alien the research data
the way she says some lines are weird
research data chromosome 24 chromosome
24 like shit no yours chromosome 24 I'm
in the movie it's this place it's hell
it always was wait are they saying it's
not actually held
thanks herb oh I just want at the end of
this whole movie for them who's
responsible for all this ooh and then
just cut to the Martians or Mars Attacks
[Laughter]
thus Portland's calm you call if you
need help okay kind of a gun step up
yeah fucking walkie talkie you know it's
like they played them using it's gone
nowhere it's like it just doesn't even
get you hyped anymore it's just like
yeah yeah it's choosing John it's
choosing who to infect look I know about
bullshit science I use a Tribble to save
my best friend don't even shrine move
I'm so sick of that music be like yeah
now it's the act is like shut the fuck
up I don't think everyone is infected or
even capable I am reading my line yeah
what did a robot write her lines and
then save them I think she's
computer-generated this is wrong I think
son you don't think this is the Brack
supposed to be the bad guy yeah is that
what they're doing this movie cannot
make that work I kinda can't believe I'm
seeing this like I just did this is not
a career move he would make like now
you're bleeding to death
what's the name of that robot from Big O
our Dorothy oh yeah you're bleeding to
do my god it is Roger oh yeah because
it's so much like the game
[Music]
videos like Super Mario in real life and
it's like this with doom but you know
supposed to be a movie actually doom
looks better than this the recent games
yeah say he looks like the guy yeah
don't leave a picture guy yeah yeah it
does look like stealth is probably not
the rock strong boy yeah just seeing him
like who am zhilie run across I'm like
oh yeah you're like the women who you
throw a desk at em or something yeah cuz
we haven't seen this yet you know just a
guy looking around a dark room all quiet
I sure hope rock music comes in for like
12 seconds we're gonna kidnap punches
wife doom human guy fighting other human
guy may be turning into monster and hell
as a metaphor yeah a metaphor god damn
manifold you have the rock in your movie
you don't need to make sense just make
it accurately huh
Semper Fi motherfucker that's my tagline
I've decided yeah yeah goes a fist fight
with a lean
remember how this movie started yeah
this is what was building up to
that was so fucking remember the bat was
no fucking way good with horns and
they're like cannon-armed gun that what
the fuck because I was wondering yeah
that I was wondering after the first few
missiles like why is this movie is such
a bad reputation but so far oh my god
and they're like surprises you with the
dumb it's like so underwhelmed still uh
no I don't know I know it's not like the
worst I still liked it better than
Mortal Kombat Mortal Kombat's more
visually interesting
Mortal Kombat Lewis violent games ever
made more but have a game yeah the whole
five minutes now monsters he shoots
weren't the monsters of their lame
excuses for I think the settles at event
horizon is still the better doom
what's that there with the kid gang
highly are you high well yeah that'll
play in I guess like like where did that
go oh I don't I guess you got a package
I guess I got a package so I'm going to
get that package that's dude Duma sucks
yeah see you next time is Jim sucks yes
see what I got
you